the truth is I've been lucky to get
nominated a a fair number of times and
won a fair enough times it never gets
easier people always ask well you must
be old hand if you if you look enough to
win you must be able to just run up
there and make a smooth speech or you
must not have flop sweat sitting in the
theater and it's been exactly as hard it
honestly I've at every Academy where
they hate to admit this but I at the
very last nanosecond I think lose lose
lose could I oh my god so it's it's just
as nerve-wracking and and when you get a
nomination that's just as exciting the
first time I ever got nominated I got
four nominations in one year and whoa
this is a good start after that if I
only got two nominations or one I felt
was a bit of a letdown but you know
kicking off that way was was great in my
my favorite memory of the the first time
I went they won two Academy Awards in
the same year and in the limo on the way
home from the awards won Oscar fell and
dented the other Oscar and I've never
fixed the dented Oscar because if people
ask about I say oh well that's my other
Oscar fell into it when the limo pulled
away it's worth it for the story